à l'école élémentaire mozart de
vélizy-villacoublay on prépare la
réouverture dans cet établissement d'une
capacité totale de 280 élèves il y a
actuellement 145 élèves par jour
la reprise totale est prévue le 22 juin
à quelques semaines seulement de la fin
de l'année scolaire
c'est toujours utile d'en voir ses
élèves oui on attend juste les
directives et puis ça va le faire
cette reprise se prépare la rectrice de
l'académie de versailles charline avenel
et présente pour expliquer
l'organisation de cette fin d'année le
retour des élèves va être préparé durant
toute cette semaine le protocole
sanitaire sera donc allégé au lieu
d'avoir au moins un mètre entre chaque
bureau il y aura un mètre entre chaque
élève donc voyez ça permet de lever la
contrainte de 10 par classe en
maternelle de 15 en élémentaire et donc
de réunir davantage d'enfants de la même
manière les enfants auront le droit de
revenir dans la course jouer avec des
ballons c'est sans doute elle la mesure
qui acte le plus concrètement le retour
à la vie normale pour les enfants
le foot ce serait un peu compliqué vu
que après si on a la balle dans les
mains il faut désinfecter tous et tout
ça me fait un peu bizarre parce que j'ai
été habitué à être dans une classe de 10
et du coup ça doit être un changement il
y aura moins de gestes barrières nous ça
va être ça va beaucoup changer cet après
midi une grande réunion était organisée
par jean michel blanquer les principaux
syndicats du secteur pour que le
protocole soient expliquées et ajustés